Welcome back to "The Tonight Show," everybody.
I'm Steve Higgins, and it's time to play...
-Password!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's meet our contestants.
To my left, she's the founder of martha.com.
Give it up for Martha Stewart!
-Oh, yeah! -Come on! Come on!
Martha, your partner this evening is the host
of NBC's "Tonight Show" and Grammy Award-winning musician,
Jimmy Fallon!
Wow. Wow. When'd you add that?
-Yeah. This afternoon.
-Your first opponent is a member of the legendary Roots crew.
Say hello to Mr. Tariq Trotter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Grammy winner. -Keep working, man.
-And his partner is starring in the limited series
"George & Tammy" premiering December 4th on Showtime.
It's Jessica Chastain.
My God.
Wow! Very nice!
The rules of the game are very simple.
I will give each of you a password.
And then you are to give a one-word clue, one word only,
to get your partner to guess that password.
The team with the most points after four words wins.
And the first clue goes to Jimmy and Tariq.
-Wow.
-The password is...
-Tariq, why don't you start us off?
-Oh, geez.
-Hm. Hmm.
-Okay. -This is Tariq.
-[ Laughs ] -Turkey.
-Thanksgiving. -Ooh, no.
You got this one.
-So we already know the one clue.
-Yeah, one clue. -Oh, it's the same?
-Same clue, but he said -- -His clue was --
-Turkey.
-Okay.
Sound.
-Gobble.
-Yeah! Wow!
[ Bell dinging ]
Whoa, man! Yes! Snap!
-You said a thousand words!
He said, "We already know the one clue.
So we know his clue..." -Playing by the rules!
And you know what? -Okay.
-♪ This is how you do it ♪
-Jessica, there you go. -Oh, sorry, Martha.
-Alright. You guys the clues. -Do we look?
-The password is...
-Who goes first? -Martha, you are up first.
-Um...
[Sweetly] pumpkin.
-Hmm.
Pumpkin.
-You said it very cute. Like, "Pumpkin!"
Is it, like, a little pumpkin? Like a "pumpkin"?
-Could be. -Could be.
I would say squash.
-Whoa!
[ Bell dinging ]
Ohh! Ohh-oh!
-We are the best at this! You kidding me?
-Oh, my God! -11...
-That was very well done. -Oh, my gosh.
You got squashed, Tariq. Sorry about that.
-That was so good! That was so good!
I love that clue. -Jimmy and Tariq.
-Alright. -Alright. Here we go.
-The password is...
-Jimmy, why don't you start us off this time?
No cheating.
[ Laughter ]
-This time. -No cheating.
-Um...
Macy's!
-Parade.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God! Okay.
The final -- The final clue --
-Jessica, are you having fun? -Yes. Yes.
This is the best game. -You're having the best time.
You guys are crushing us. -Okay. Jessica, Martha.
This one is worth one million points.
-The password is...
-Does Jessica get to say anything?
-Yes, it's her turn. She's going to start it off.
-Good. I want her to have fun.
-If she wins, it's one million points.
-Oh, my goodness. -Who starts?
-Jessica. -Jessica's gonna start.
-Oh, geez. Okay.
[ Chuckles ] Can I move my hands at all?
-Yes. That's legal. -No!
What are you talking about?!
-Ready? -Yes, she can.
-Football!
-Oh, absolutely not. Absolutely not.
-Touchdown. -Yes.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. My thanks to Jessica Chastain.
The champion. Jessica and Tariq.
Martha Stewart! Come on! Higgins. I love ya.
We'll be right back with more "Tonight Show." Stick around.